podcasts Are Taking Over YouTube
everyone from financial influencers and
Gamers to fitness models and vloggers
all suddenly have a podcast
this is in stark contrast to everything
the media has been telling us our
attention span is shrinking Tick Tock is
beating YouTube long form content is
dying YouTube shorts are taking over and
on and on and on
the reality is that this is completely
false in fact companies are actually
backing away from short form content
meta has eliminated their Rio's Creator
fund and Tick Tock is becoming more and
more like YouTube conversely what seems
to be doing really well is actually
podcasts despite them breaking basically
every creative rule you can think of
for starters there are one to two hours
long if not longer so thereby no means
catering to our short attention spans
also there's no fancy editing and sound
effects music Graphics coherent
storytelling or any of that more times
than not podcasts are just conversations
that naturally jump from one topic to
another not to mention there's only one
episode per week or maybe only one
episode per month
yet despite all these quote-unquote
shortfalls podcasts are performing
better than ever the iced coffee hour
has nearly half a million Subs the pbd
podcast has 700 000 Subs Lex Friedman
has nearly 3 million subs and heck even
Logan Paul's podcast as four and a half
million Subs it seems like podcasts are
the new vlogging where every YouTuber
has a podcast Channel and they're all
racked in it millions of views YouTube
is of course trying to capitalize on
this trend by pushing podcasts as much
as possible just yesterday YouTube
rolled out a podcast functionality on
the music app you no longer have to be a
premium member to listen to podcasts in
the background but speaking of vlogging
it that Trend it didn't last for too
long eventually most bloggers quit and
it was only a select few channels like
Casey neistat who have been able to
survive in the genre over the long term
and even he took a massive break so why
are podcasts taking over the platform
and is this just a short-term fad or the
future of YouTube
taking a look back the explosion of
podcasts on YouTube can be traced back
till one man Joe Rogan Rogan basically
invented the podcasting Niche here on
YouTube having started his podcast The
Joe Rogan Experience way back in 2009
given his background as a comedian and a
show host on mainstream media he was
naturally pretty good at having engaging
and enticing conversations his show was
almost like a good mythical morning
which was also blowing up at the time
but instead of focusing on production
and entertainment value Rogan would
focus on educational and intellectual
value this isn't to say that he
instantly blew up but it gave him a
differentiating factor which he leaned
into over the years he would interview
everyone from Elon Musk and the Neil
deGrasse Tyson to David Blaine and
Bernie Sanders over time this gave him
access to an extremely large audience in
fact by the end of 2020 he added 10
million subscribers and a nearly 3
billion views but all of this would
change in 2021 you see it Spotify
offered Rogan an exclusivity deal that
was worth as much as 200 million dollars
Rogan would of course take the deal and
he would move his podcasting over to
Spotify starting at the end of 2020.
conventional wisdom would tell you that
this is terrible news for YouTube
Spotify had effectively poached the most
popular podcaster in the world and with
that who knows how many loyal listeners
they had converted to Spotify but this
is where things get dicey Rogan has
obviously still an extraordinarily
popular pulling in an average of 11
million listeners per episode for
perspective even the most popular
mainstream media show will only poison
3.24 million euros per episode so Rogan
is obviously crushing it but that
doesn't mean that you YouTube is
performing poorly without it in fact
twitch has found that large creators
leaving the platform in surprisingly
beneficial for them here's the thing
when there's a super large crater in a
given Niche they basically soak up all
the attention this makes it extremely
difficult for smaller creators to gain
traction as viewers are simply satisfied
with the larger Creator but when the
larger crater switches platforms or
takes a break this allows for content
from smaller creators to be pushed at
the same time that viewers are looking
to fill a void this creates The Perfect
Storm for smaller creators to explode in
popularity as was the case with twitch
apparently ninja leaving twitch allowed
for 5 to 6 new streamers to take his
place and it seems that this same
phenomenon has played out on a much
bigger scale with podcasting on YouTube
the best part of all of this for
platforms is that the Creator who left
often tends to come back Broken Steel
with Spotify for example only lasts
three and a half years this means that
the deal will expire in early to
mid-2024 which is only a year away if he
returns to YouTube at this point I'm
sure he'll do great but he would no
longer be the only podcasting Giant on a
platform he would simply be a giant
[Music]
so that explains the audience side of
things Joe Rogan had an extremely big
podcasting presence on YouTube and his
departure left tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions of fans looking for
an alternative allowing for
up-and-coming creators to blow up but
what about the Creator side of things if
you take a look at the biggest creators
on the platform like Mr Beast Iraq and
Mr who's the boss you'll see that
they're all taking the exact opposite
approach every second of their videos is
all about constant stimulation text on
screen sound effects constant Cuts super
high energy and it tons of money clearly
this is working out great for them and
while this style would definitely evolve
over time and it's most likely the
future of YouTube I mean there's a
reason that movies are so popular people
love high production value content so
with that being said podcasters won't be
taking on these behemoths anytime soon
but what podcasting does offer is a
super high Roi on a much smaller scale
take The Upfront work for example
creating one of my videos takes about 20
hours of work between me and my editors
creating something on the level of Mr
who's the boss takes hundreds of hours
of work and creating something on the
level of Mr Beast takes thousands of
hours of work but at that end of the day
all of this effort only translates to a
10 to 20 minute long video creating a
podcast on the other hand only takes
three to five hours of work worst case
scenario and it might take 10 hours of
work but at the end of it you have hours
of content so the ratio between work
input and content output is simply
ridiculous and that's just the first
Advantage the second Advantage is that
the demographics of podcast listeners
are insane giving the educational nature
of podcasts it simply doesn't appeal to
the general audience which largely
limits how big these channels can get
but the people that it does reach is
insane as these people are generally
High performers looking to improve
themselves learn and get to the next
level in fact 30 percent of podcast
listeners make a quarter million per
year that right there is a gold mine for
advertisers leading to super high ad
rates on podcasts not to mention them
given the length of podcasts you can
stuff in like 20 mid-roll ads leading to
even more income but honestly the money
and these smaller advantages the
real advantage in my opinion is the
opportunity to network as a podcaster
you're constantly reaching out to
leaders that you would have otherwise
never reached out to people like Elon
Musk and the Mark Zuckerberg and you get
to meet and talk with these people for
hours
so you've got low effort high output
Evergreen content that appeals to a high
value audience and allows you to network
with the most successful people in the
world no wonder every YouTuber is trying
to capitalize on this opportunity
[Music]
not only are podcasts great for creators
viewers and advertisers but they're also
great for platforms one of the biggest
challenges for modern social media
platforms is trying to keep your
attention attention is really the
currency of the modern world if you're
able to Garner attention and everything
else will follow this is why social
media platforms are constantly tinkering
with their algorithms and looking for
the perfect balance it just so happens
to be that podcasts are extraordinarily
easy to recommend as they pull in a
stupid amount of watch time given their
length podcasts often boast 20 30 40
minutes of average watch time but not
only do podcasts pull in a stupid amount
of watch time but they also build habits
and regular viewership here's the thing
people aren't listening to podcasts on a
Friday evening when they're trying to
unwind rather podcasts usually make
their way into people his daily routines
we're talking about commutes to work
taking a walk cooking folding the
laundry doing chores Etc more times than
not podcasts are the perfect tool to
make these mundane tasks more productive
and it becomes a part of the routine so
platforms like YouTube and Spotify don't
really have to push podcasts too hard
when the time comes people go and find a
podcast they want to listen to by
themselves this makes podcasts likely
the easiest way for these platforms to
Garner and retain attention but it's not
all good news with everyone jumping onto
the podcasting scene there's no question
that this area is going to become
saturated if it isn't already I mean
there's only so many Finance podcasts
gaming podcasts Fitness podcasts and
food podcasts that people can listen to
also something else to note is that much
of the popularity of these podcasts can
be attributed to the mystery surrounding
the guests take Mr Beast for example
before podcast started blowing up on
YouTube the intricacies of his business
and operations were largely a mystery
but now that Jimmy has made his rounds
on dozens of podcasts much of the
mystery surrounding his business is now
gone people's Curiosities have been
satiated and a perfect example of this
is Alex hormuzi in the early days there
was a lot of curiosity regarding who
this Lumberjack is and how he made a
hundred million dollars as such his
first appearance on the iced coffee hour
pulled in nearly a million views but his
second appearance on the show only
garnered 300 000 views and his latest
appearance only garnered 200 000 views
this isn't to say that these podcasts
are any less valuable but simply that
the mystery and interest Ronnie Alex has
faded away and as a more and more
podcast interviewed the same people it's
likely that Alex's situation will become
a trend now of course there will always
be new figures of interest but there's
no question that this list is not nearly
as exhaustive as it once used to be
which raises the question
sustainable really is podcasting
none of this is to say that podcasting
is going to die into Oblivion like Vine
but there's also no question that the
area is becoming oversaturated and
there's only a limited amount of
attention and a limited number of guests
the early signs of this are already
starting to surface newer podcasts
aren't garnering nearly as much momentum
popular podcasts are getting most of
their views and growth from short form
content and podcasts are having to
repeat guests more and more so I think
it's safe to say that the golden days of
podcasts are right now or are already
behind us again this isn't to say that
podcasts are going to disappear into
Oblivion but it's more than likely that
many of the newer podcasters won't end
up making it and the Legacy podcast will
stabilize at a much more modest view
count similar to vlogging vlogging isn't
dead but it's also not what it used to
be back in 2015 and 2016 and that may
very well be the fate of podcasts as
well but that's just what I think do you
guys listen to podcasts if so which one
is your favorite comment that down below
also drop a like if you'd like to see
more videos about social media trends
and of course consider checking out our
Discord community so just for the video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one